des devantures placardées des artères
bouchées une place et midi Gamelin
désertée à quelques mètres de là une
arrestation pour vol à la SAQ
l'un des principaux enjeux du secteur
c'est de la cohabitation avec une
itinérance plus visible beaucoup de
nouveaux visages plus de problèmes de
santé mentale je dirais plus de
problèmes de consommation aussi ça
dérange les citoyens qui sont pas
habitués et qui ont pas nécessairement
les outils pour dîner avec ça un
sentiment d'insécurité que ne partage
pas tous les résidents j'aime cette
quartier parce que
la vie est ici est très actif les gens
qui ont peut-être peur des gens qui sont
SDF ou quoi que ce soit c'est juste
qu'ils sont incompris en annonçant sa
fermeture Archambault cite les problèmes
liés au tissus urbain et que Montréal a
fait du quartier un laboratoire de
mixité le Quartier des spectacles
c'était la même chose aujourd'hui c'est
vu comme étant un succès mais il y avait
des périodes il y avait beaucoup de
travaux il y avait des enjeux
d'itinérance aussi dans ce secteur donc
je pense que faut pas être laxiste mais
ça prend quand même une certaine
patience mais les signes de
revitalisation dans cette zone
spécifique du métro Berry femmes sont
rares oui à des projets immobiliers qui
demandent du temps pour pouvoir voir
leur émergence des logements des projets
privés et des projets aussi également
publics mais on travaille il ne se passe
pas rien qu'une tout raconté début 2021
n'a toujours pas vu le jour par exemple
en attendant on mise sur une animation
saisonnière inclusive les jardins
gamelins ce qui fonctionne au jardin
c'est d'être capable de faire rencontrer
des publics le fait quand vous avez une
certaine angle de personnes en situation
d'itinérance qui sont dans cet espace là
c'est un peu sécurisant mais quand vous
avez 1000 personnes sur le même site
avec le même nombre de personnes en
situation d'itinérance mais là à ce
moment-là le sentiment de sécurité est
beaucoup plus élevé et plus intéressant
qu'en est-il de la criminalité dans le
Grand Quartier du village je vous dirais
que la criminalité dans le secteur est
stable en fait si l'on regarde les 10
dernières années les crimes contre les
personnes et contre les biens sont même
en légère diminution il manque les
données du dernier trimestre de 2022
mais certaines catégorie ont demandé
plus de travail aux policiers l'année
dernière les introductions par
effraction sont peut-être en plus grand
nombre incluant les voies de fées puis
je vous dirai les vols de véhicules et
oui ces infractions peuvent avoir un
impact sur l'attractivité du secteur
même si l'on compte 10 commerces
supplémentaires en 2022 les enjeux de
sécurité c'est le frais numéro 1 en ce
moment au développement économique du
quartier est-ce que ça s'améliore j'ai
l'impression que ça s'améliore la rue
Sainte-Catherine doit être refaite à
neuf l'année prochaine une autre
occasion de donner un nouveau souffle
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal